hi this is Kim from Khan Academy and
today I'm learning more about article
six of the US Constitution Article six
is as will soon see kind of a
constitutional grab bag it covers debts
religious tests for office and it
establishes the Constitution as the
supreme law of the land to learn more
about what binds these diverse ideas
together I sought out the help of two
experts Kermit Roosevelt is a professor
of law specializing in constitutional
law and conflict of laws at the
University of Pennsylvania Law School
and Michael Ramsey is professor of law
and director of international and
comparative law programs at the
University of San Diego School of Law so
let's start out talking about the debts
portion of article six professor
Roosevelt why were the framers so
interested in dead what was the
historical context that led them to
explicitly address debt in article six
well debt is important generally because
nations often need to borrow money and
specifically with the Constitution and
the Articles of Confederation the US
government had been borrowing money to
pay for the Revolutionary War so there
was a question we're moving from a sort
of loose confederation almost like a
treaty between nations
under the Articles of Confederation to a
single unitary country with a stronger
national government under the
Constitution and there's a question is
it still the same country will the new
United States pay the debts of the old
United States now there's a general
principle of international law that a
successor government undertakes the
obligations of the predecessor so you
you wouldn't necessarily think this
would be a problem but I think they were
particularly concerned because the idea
of a republic was a somewhat new one at
least in the 18th century somewhat
unusual one and the the the change of a
Republican government might cause some
worries in Europe where where this money
was owed so I think they just wanted to
reassure all of the creditors that even
if they were changing their method of
government that that wasn't going to
affect any of the debts what might have
happened had they decided not to pay
those debts
if they decided not to pay the debts
then other countries would probably have
been much less willing to lend money to
the new United States because they might
have thought well you know another
change in government could occur there
was substantial question throughout the
world whether the United States would be
able to survive in the face of all the
challenges that they had after gaining
their independence
so in order to make it seem that they
that the United States was a country
that could be trusted a country that
could be expected to stick around and
not collapse into chaos or revert to
colonial status one of the most
important things for them was to show
that the the debts would be honored
because a failure to honor debts would
suggest that the country did not in fact
have true sovereignty and was not
prepared to be a actor on the
international stage that could be
trusted another interesting thing to
contrast this to is the treatment of
debts after the Civil War where of
course the United States the federal
government paid its own debts but
there's a provision in the 14th
amendment explicitly repudiating the
Confederate debt so if you loaned money
to the Confederate States of America
you're never getting that back because
we didn't treat that as a valid
government that would be continued going
forward another thing that it
illustrates is that the Constitution in
some respects was was a visionary
document that was concerned with a
long-term future of the United States
but in other respects it responded to
very immediate practical problems that
the framers faced in their day they were
thinking about not not just the future
of the country for the ages and they
were thinking about that but but they
weren't thinking just about that they
were they were also thinking about
reassuring France with respect to the
debts that existed right at that moment
so there's a lot going on in article 6
and specifically it talks about the
Constitution as the supreme law of the
land so what's important about that
statement what's important about that is
that it means the Constitution is our
highest law it prevails over any other
kind of law in a conflict so one thing
that that means is the Constitution is
supreme over state law and then the
Constitution actually goes on to talk
about that a little bit more but it also
means the Constitution is supreme over
federal law so
everyone is bound by the Constitution
the states can't go against that
Congress can't go past it the president
can't violate constitutional
restrictions the Constitution is really
the last word it's the pinnacle or the
keystone of the arch of American
democracy and that's why we can say that
things are unconstitutional that laws
are unconstitutional and therefore
invalid and most importantly it's why
the Supreme Court can say that laws are
unconstitutional and not in and invalid
it creates a superior law that that
limits the laws that can be passed by
the other parts of the government it
creates a hierarchy of laws and in doing
so it assures that we have a single set
of rules that applies to all the states
and to the federal government and it
can't be changed
except by an amendment which is
relatively difficult to do there's a
procedure in the Constitution for how
you can amend the Constitution but until
amending the Constitution as as written
is our superior law and that that was
different from the way that the framers
the law rules the framers were used to
under the English system where they
didn't have a written constitution and
an unwritten Constitution but that that
Constitution was subject to change by
Parliament so has this supremacy of a
constitution been tested over time there
haven't been a lot of claims that the
Constitution is not supreme so generally
speaking everyone gives at least lip
service to this idea what's been tested
is more the question of who gets to
decide what the Constitution means and
when something conflicts with it so if
you want the Constitution and federal
law to be supreme probably you would
want to have someone in the federal
government deciding when there's a
conflict say with state law and the
forms that resistance has taken over the
years or more States saying not you know
we can go against the Constitution we're
above the Constitution but States saying
we don't think what we're doing violates
the Constitution right and you the
Supreme Court you think it does but
you're wrong in the nine
century just before the Civil War the
Supreme Court decided in the Dred Scott
case that african-americans could not be
citizens of the United States even if
they were freed slaves and President
Lincoln believes that that was wrong he
said that there was nothing in the
Constitution that denied that the
ability of them to be citizens and and
he said that the Supreme Court had
misunder interpreted the Constitution
and he would not accept the Supreme
Court's ruling in that regard later in
the 20th century the Supreme Court held
that the Constitution barred segregation
particularly in in schools in the Brown
versus Board of Education case but many
southern governors and other
institutions throughout the South
thought that the Supreme Court had
gotten that one wrong
and they refused to abide by what the
Supreme Court had said the Constitution
means what they said was not the
Constitution doesn't bind us but we know
what the Constitution means better than
you Supreme Court you're wrong you're
making this up it's political it's not
judging another thing that article 6
talks about is religious tests why were
the framers so interested in preventing
religious tests in government what sort
of historical evils were they trying to
prevent so this is connected to the
basic idea of the separation of church
and state and you separate church and
state really to protect both of those
things so you want to protect religion
from being corrupted by political
considerations but you also want to
protect your political system from being
a battleground between rival religions
so where this comes from is that in
England they had had a series of what
they called test acts and what the test
acts did was it required that for people
to be eligible for government offices
that that people had to be members of
the Church of England and that other
other religious groups they were barred
by the test acts from holding government
office so actually many of those
minority religions many adherents of
those ended up coming to the American
colonies to gain this
measure of religious freedom the
Pilgrims were an example of that there
were there was a Catholic colony and in
Maryland and just generally speaking
many of the people many of the colonists
who came over were people who were not
part of the main established Church in
England and so you can see why they
would not want to have something like
the test acts and they wanted to make
clear that in the new national
government that that any religion or no
religion would would be allowed for for
government office holders do you think
it's true that we don't have religious
tests or oaths in the United States how
about the practice of swearing on a
Bible during the presidential
inauguration
well the practice of swearing on a Bible
is very interesting as is the fact that
when the president recites the oath of
office every president going back to
George Washington has added on to the
end of it so help me God there's
actually an oath in the Constitution the
president has to swear to preserve
protect and defend the Constitution but
the Constitution doesn't say so help me
God the president's just add that on on
their own and actually that sort of
illustrates the way in which the
Constitution treats religion which is it
can't be part of government in an
official sense but we know that members
of government are also people and they
have religious beliefs that are
important to them and we don't demand
that they exclude religion from their
lives we just demand that it be
separated from government authority so
you can swear on a Bible if you want to
you don't have to you can swear on some
other religious book we had a member of
Congress take an oath of office on a
Quran so individual government officials
are allowed to include religion insofar
as it's about them personally you know
what you think is appropriate to mark
this occasion
what solemnity is this oath for you you
can do that but we can't require it and
they can't make the exercise of their
power religious in nature so you can't
you know as a government official
exercise your power
on religious grounds something that
strikes me about article six is that it
addresses so many different things do
you have a sense of why debts and
constitutional supremacy and religious
tests are all in one article article six
as you said is a little bit of a grab
bag it's not entirely clear how these
different pieces of article six relate
to each other and I think they were just
things that the framers wanted in the
Constitution and didn't know for sure
where else to put them I'm not exactly
sure why the debts are there if I had to
say something about article six it would
be it's sort of the glue that holds the
constitutional architecture together so
maybe the decks are in there to explain
the continuity between the US government
under the Articles of Confederation and
the US government under the Constitution
then the Supremacy Clause explains how
all of the different parts of the
federal system are supposed to fit
together and what the Supremacy Clause
is saying is the Constitution is above
all of them the Constitution connects
them all everyone has to abide by the
Constitution and it tells you you know
the Constitution is the highest law then
you've got federal law and then below
that is state law so that if there's a
conflict between federal law and state
law the federal law is going to win and
then the last part of article 6 is sort
of doing the same thing because you know
what holds the country together what
binds people into a single people in a
lot of countries at the time of the
founding it was religion right religion
was the glue that held the society
together and if you weren't a member of
that religion you were an outsider he
were a second-class citizen you would be
shunned and and not given equal rights
in some ways the last Clause of article
6 says something sort of similar about
America except it explicitly says it's
not religion that binds us together
right no religious test can be required
but you do have to take an oath what do
you have to pledge to support you have
to pledge to support the Constitution so
there again it's telling you the
Constitution is what we all have in
common that's what makes us Americans
that really is the glue that binds our
society together
so we've learned that article 6 is as
professor Roosevelt put it the glue that
binds the country together in assuming
the debts from the era of the Articles
of Confederation article 6 establish the
continuity of US government it also
placed the Constitution not religion as
the supreme law of the United States to
learn more about article 6 visit the
National Constitution Center's
interactive Constitution and Khan
Academy's resources on US government and
politics